Nein, wir sind hier nicht
in einem Star-Wars-Film gelandet,
sondern in einem realen Lichtschwert-Kampf.
In dieser französischen Turnhalle in einem
Pariser Vorort verwandeln sich junge Sportler
in Kämpfer der dunklen Seite der Macht
aus der Star-Wars-Saga:
Hier dreht sich alles um Star Wars.
Als Kind habe ich
von Star Wars geträumt und davon,
ein Lichtschwert zu besitzen
und damit zu spielen wie in den Filmen.
Egal, wie alt man ist, man kann
damit Spaß haben wie im Film.
Lichtschwert-Fechten
ist ein Trend in Frankreich
– inspiriert vom Star-Wars-Universum,
das von US-Regisseur
George Lucas geschaffen wurde.
Mittlerweile werden regelmäßig
Lichtschwerter-Turniere organisiert
und Anthony Lococo gilt als Favorit.
Er hat die vergangenen beiden
nationalen Meisterschaften gewonnen.
Dieses Mal kämpft er mit
fast 40 Konkurrenten
aus ganz Frankreich um den Titel.
Gewinner ist, wer nach drei Minuten in
Führung liegt oder 15 Punkte erreicht.
Für einen Treffer am Kopf gibt es
fünf Punkte, für die Beine drei.
Ein echter Sport, findet Anton André.
Viele machen das, weil sie Star Wars mögen.
Für andere ist die Ästhetik wichtig
oder der Sport.
Für mich trifft eher Letzteres zu.
Ich mag natürlich Star Wars,
aber Sport und Disziplin sind mir wichtiger.
Eine der wenigen Lichtschwert-Fechterinnen
ist Amandine Lecomte.
Es gibt nicht viele Frauen,
aber die wenigen Frauen hier
sind mit ganzem Herzen dabei.
Wir wollen hier Spaß haben und zeigen,
dass wir das auch können.
Anthony Lococo ist seit drei Jahren
begeistert vom Lichtschwert-Fechten
– ein Pionier der Disziplin.
Der Französische Fechtverband hat die
Sportart im Mai 2018 offiziell anerkannt –
als erster und einziger
Fechtverband der Welt.
Wir versuchen, Jugendliche zu begeistern.
Und das Star-Wars-Universum
ist für sie attraktiv.
Das versuchen wir,
auf unseren Sport zu übertragen.
Lichtschwert-Fechten ist ein richtiger Sport.
Wenn Sie es mal ausprobieren können,
werden Sie sehen,
dass es nach fünf Minuten
sehr anstrengend ist.
Seine Leidenschaft für das
Lichtschwert-Fechten
gibt Anthony Lococo an andere weiter
– als Trainer.
Sein Verein ist einer von mehr
als 90 in ganz Frankreich.
Insgesamt fechten schon rund 2000
Franzosen mit dem Lichtschwert.
Ich finde es toll, Werte zu vermitteln
– wie bei allen Sportarten –
an Erwachsene und auch an Jüngere.
Man kann ins
Star-Wars-Universum eintauchen,
und Lichtschwert-Fechten
basiert auf Kampfkunst.
Und es ist wirklich eine Kunst, so zu kämpfen.
Hier beim Wettkampf hoffen alle,
dass Lichtschwert-Fechten wie traditionelles
Fechten irgendwann olympisch wird.
In Frankreich gibt es immer mehr Vereine.
Auch in den USA.
In Europa sagen sich viele:
Die Franzosen haben Lichtschwert-Fechten
offiziell anerkannt, warum nicht auch wir?
Der Sport wird auf der ganzen Welt beliebter.
Dieses Mal ist Anthony Lococo
nur Zweiter geworden.
Doch Medaillen sind nicht so wichtig.
Der Lichtschwert-Community
geht es vielmehr darum,
dass ihre Leidenschaft auch andere ansteckt
– genauso wie beim Star-Wars-Fieber.